What's your favorite Morphe game? I'd have to think about that. There's quite a few good ones.
Okay, we'll play a couple with him and then I'll read more on Morphe's adventures in Europe.
Yeah, I actually think the fame of the opera game is one of the greatest mysteries in chess.
Like, why are people so obsessed with it? I think it's because maybe of the circumstances
of the game make people interested in it, but the game itself is extremely unremarkable.
Well, if I had to think about what my Morphe number is, probably not as much as you think.
So, who beat Morphe? I guess Anderson. You'd have to probably go through Steinitz and then Lasker.
And my guess is Lasker already lost to someone who lost to someone whom I played, I'm sure.
Uh, Bavinic? I don't think played a manual Lasker.
Yeah, Morphe's a super interesting character. Super interesting character.
Oh my gosh. Did I just blunder my queen? No. I have this move.
I am not ghost fan, Mike. I'm American. But I should have gone to the other rook.
Shoot. That was a very imprecise execution by me.
Let's go here. That's okay. I'm still a piece up. I just have to be very careful.
Well, doesn't being born in a country make you... I mean, I don't understand.
Don't people realize there's a difference between your ethnic background and
your nationality? It's not the same thing.
The opera game is not overrated. I agree. No, it's a good game. I never said it's a bad game
or it shouldn't be shown. I just think it's often called the best game of all time,
or the most instructive game of all time, which I think is absolute BS.
Like, indisputable BS. There's so many more instructive games.
Am I messing this up? Oh, my gosh. I think I messed this up.
Ah, here. Back in charge. That was a poor technique, but I think I've hunted him down.
Morphy would be proud of this one. King a4, he has to play, but then even knight c3 wins.
Yeah, this is winning. Gosh, I was very close to letting that one slip, because if he had...
My knights are hanging. That did not look great.
Yeah, but I'm winning a bit less here. I should have known that. It's embarrassing.
You probably looked this line up.
As a chess coach, the opera game seems important to me. I concede the point. It's worth showing,
and it's worth including in books and stuff. I just think there's a whole untapped...
The amount of classical games that are just as instructive, if not more instructive,
that don't make their way into a lot of chess books,
is sort of a pet peeve of mine when it comes to listing good games and stuff.
Okay, but it's hard for me to tell you off the top of my head what are some underrated games
that people should know. But if I thought about it, I could generate some games.
Who is the strongest player you have faced in classical chess? In terms of highest rated,
I faced Wesley when he was over 2,800, Kramnik, and Fabi when he was exactly 2,800.
Yeah, so that would be the highest rated.
So I drew Wesley, beat Fabi. I've said before, amazingly, I'm one and a half out of two
against players over 2,800 by miracle because of Wesley and Fabi.
Now, Wesley was just a Berlin draw, so that doesn't really count.
But it's just because the sample size is tiny.
Yeah, I'm busted here, I think, unfortunately.
This guy definitely has my number.
There's just something about his play style that makes it so hard for me to play quickly.
I mean, the Berlin draw is not something you have to study. You can just like know it or not know it.
I saw the video when you were talking like Wesley, so yeah, I mean, that video is pretty funny, but
to be completely honest, I played the Berlin against Daniel.
I don't know if you can see it, but it's a little bit of a mess, but it's a little bit of a mess.
I played the Berlin against Daniel and I am regretting it because he is a terrible chess player.
I have no idea how he's able to maintain the speed in these situations.
I've talked about the Kramnik game and I've written a Chess.com article about it.
I know he would never say that. I'm just joking. Wesley is like the nicest person in the world.
I'm just getting smashed here.
Hanging by a thread.
Maybe Rook A would be one. It's worth playing. I was hoping he would pre-move, honestly.
I shoot. Takes.
Unbelievable. What a move. What a freaking move. Oh no! No, no, no, no. I didn't mean to do that.
Oh no. No. I made the wrong move there. Of course he found that.
Ah! Unbelievable. That was an easy flag if I just didn't know.
If I took on e6, maybe that would have been better. Prolonged the process.
But I deserve to lose that after playing like a complete idiot in the tactical sequence.
Always finding sh** like this.
Pathetic.
Yeah Rook takes h3. Without it, he's losing on the spot.
But I somehow managed to let him promote the second pawn, which is dumb.
No comment.
Obviously play fxc6 here. What the hell is f6? fxc6 and e7, I've got a shot here. So stupid.
Just meltdown. I probably maybe would have even won the game because it's hard for him to get rid of both of my pawns.
Okay, now I'm blundering pieces.
Maybe knight c7? No, this is lost.
Ruined the whole momentum of these two stupid games.
Oh my god.
Well, he went from a piece up to a piece down, so that's gonna help.
Unless I screw this up, which is likely, but...
Let's see if I can keep my composure this time.
Unforgivable. Mental lapse that last game.
I'm still lost, I think. But at least I have a chance.
If he's basically able to turn on the jets whenever he wants, like...
Let's see if I can keep him under wraps.
Nope, I didn't mean to do that either. Rook b4.
But okay, this I should be able to flag him, maybe?
This is another stupid move, to give him the passers.
Stupid.
Looks like I managed to lose it.
Seriously?
What's going on here?
I don't know why I did that. I'm trying to flag him here.
Jesus! Get it together, man. Oh my gosh.
Oh my goodness. These two games are driving me crazy.
So many mistakes. Okay, now he's maybe tilted, hopefully.
I'm going to repeat the line. Okay, so he goes again, knight a5.
I mean, I've got to do what I've got to do in that game.
The last two days I've had a bunch of these crazy moments.
Trying to hold out.
But again, I'm repeating this line, where somehow I allow the trade of bishops.
And it's hard to break through the bind. I need to look this up.
Man, let's see if I can get another win here while he's frustrated.
I gave him so many chances that game.
But somehow I was able to just keep enough pieces on the board.
Okay. Moving on. All's well that ends well.
Let's try this very interesting move before.
Yeah, I can't get out of anything when I put my mind to it.
Which is what frustrates me about the game that I lost.
The fact that I literally got it so close and then made one stupid decision.
But that's blitz. That's just what it is.
My position is interesting. Okay, bishop e3 maybe.
I'm still going to do the Morphy thing, but after I finish this match.
Chess is so brutal. You literally do so much to win a game.
And then you make one little dumb move. And that's all it takes.
I don't know how I won the last game, given that I was down a full piece and a pawn for no comp.
I ended up blundering two pieces in a row.
Somehow I'm getting my pieces out here, out of the gates.
Okay, my headphones are dying.
Both of you are tilted as hell. I mean, I don't believe I am, but I guess you know better.
I haven't lost two games in a row in like five days, so I think I'm able to keep myself together.
I was a little tilted first half of that last game, but I did just enough to keep myself in it.
Why do mods keep deleting questions about the speedrun?
Well, because I've asked many, many times at this point for people to respect my wishes during the stream.
And the answer to will there be a speedrun game is always the same, which is that I never know until it happens.
Like, if I feel like it at the end, I do one. If not, I don't.
Which is why I always request that people don't watch the stream if the only thing that you find enjoyable in my content is the speedrun.
Which is fine. You're not telling me what you're allowed to find enjoyable or not.
But I would advise you that it would be a frustrating experience to watch the stream if the only reason you're watching it is because you're hoping for a speedrun.
This is really pretty, by the way. Look at this. Oh, look at this. Rook A7, Rook A1 mate. There we go.
Now we're cooking.
That's freaking right. Eat it. You like some of that? You want some more of that, huh?
Alright, let's play B5 this time. Just keep winning, keep winning, keep winning.
I hope that's reasonable, by the way. It's nothing personal or like, oh, you know, you said something toxic.
But it can definitely get really, really incessant when people are spamming it.
Yeah, but he was already lost. He was down in exchange, and I don't think there was much he could have done there.
He is very strong. He drives me crazy, this guy. He always finds a way to get to me in the end.
So he's going to win a couple games, but if I can avoid tilting it, I'll be good.
Bye-bye, speedrun. Bye-bye.
Streamers play Genshin for string-string bounty. I mean, the problem with Genshin to Dianya is, you know, last game was just a classic game with what makes Dianya a good Blitz player, you know.
But in classical chess, Dianya would never win that game. That's why I'm saying classical chess and Dianya struggle.
All right. Let's try a five.
Dianya broke his speedrun.
Okay. This looks like a pretty decent position, actually. Nothing better than that.
I'm looking at knight b4.
There's some beautiful lines there, but none of it works, of course.
Okay. I need to move. This is always what he does.
Makes me think in critical moments. How dare you. How dare you!
Force yourself to trust my intuition.
Hey, don't insult my darkscore, Bishop.
This is the key. This is the key to my position.
You want to be toxic and banned? You want to be toxic and banned? You can toxic and ban.
If you want to be toxic and get banned, I can ban you. I mean, if that's what you want, toxic and get banned, you can get banned.
You want to get banned? All right. Let's go g6.
All right. Here's a ban, asshole. You want to be toxic and get banned? To Jospin? To Dianya?
It's fun. Okay. This is a fun position. This is why I love the knight Rf. This is why I love the knight Rf.
This position right here is why I freaking love the knight Rf.
Okay. But let's actually win the game, and then I can start talking.
Okay.
Oh, okay. I see. Good thing I said no.
Wow, Avenger, that's too complicated for me to understand.
Wait, who is insane? War Bush League from Dianya?
Dianya playing typical garbage tricks in knight Rf? I mean, I have a problem with Dianya beating me.
It's more the way that he beats me. It's more garbage tricks, and he knows they're garbage.
Spank, spank this loser.
All right.
Have you played Emery Tate? No. Well, Emery has passed away, but no, I never played Emery Tate.
When did you become a GM? 18.
Okay, so we've righted the ship after that disaster of a game that I lost. Desastre.
It really is a very funny clip. No, that is one of the funniest things ever in the chess world.
Yeah, no religion, no politics. What do they say avoid at the family table?
Yeah, religion and politics, I think, are the two things you avoid on a Twitch stream.
How many times have I played Geary? Zero? Zero in OTB.
That's an underrated clip, the Hans, why is he so smart? Yeah, that one is hilarious.
That one is honestly very, very, very, very funny.
Toxicaband. Want to be Toxicaband? Let's go here. How many times? Many, many, many, many.
There are certain videos, and I think everybody has those videos that you just come back to from time to time.
You just watch them on a cycle, and every once in a while, you need to rewatch it because it's so good.
Yeah, this guy is frustration-inducing for sure, but I've got a nice bind on the position.
When I'm up on time in the late-middle game against him, I usually win.
The problems usually start if I enter time pressure because he's so good at generating problems.
Time pressure.
Spasibo Shekelek, congratulating me for beating Carlsen. Spasibo bolshoi.
This game is over Red Rover population. Danny Wrench.
Oh, I found something sexy.
Bishop takes d5, knight d8, and he has to give up his queen. This is a funny construction.
All right, now we're in charge.
I think bishop d7 is the best, but okay.
Okay, bishop c6 was also good, but okay.
Now I can play simply a bishop g7, but okay.
You're better than a card, yes.
But this is a very good Sicilian for black, and okay, I can't solve him.
I don't think I have the energy for that right now at this advanced hour.
Have I ever played a match versus Hans? Yeah, many, many, many. Of course I have.
Hikaru said you're better than him at everything. Yeah, exactly.
Kramnik does have a pretty high view of himself, that is true. Can't argue with that.
But he has good reason to.
Oh, God, what are my views on Hans? I thought we were over that. That's old news.
I can't muster up the energy to talk about that anymore. It is what it is. It's over now.
We'll see. We'll see, I mean, we'll see how Hans does.
You know, we'll just wait and see.
Well, I would like to not get sued, yes, but I promised Hans at the start
that I would give a fair, objective evaluation of the situation, and I think I was able to do that
without unsubstantiated opinions.
Okay, let's go here.
But how do you feel? You don't know that. You don't know that Hans is not going to be invited anywhere.
And Magnus controls everything that's totally not, it's not necessarily true.
I mean, a lot of organizers might take Hans's side. In fact, the court of public opinion, I think,
really does believe that Magnus did not act appropriately vis-à-vis his withdrawal.
So Magnus just might have to suck it up and play Hans.
Because the one thing that to me is without, I mean, I could bet, you know, silver dollar on
is that Hans did not cheat in the Singfield Cup game.
Can we get a peaceful resolution? Well, that's always what I want.
I think a peaceful resolution would be possible because the positives that came of this
is that the anti-cheating measures are taken more seriously now, and that's a good thing.
Now, would Magnus and Hans ever, like, shake hands and, you know, let bygones be bygones?
Well, that would probably require Magnus to make a public statement
that he withdraws his accusations of cheating from, like, the Singfield Cup.
I don't think we're going to see something like that.
What was your favorite part of living in the Bay Area? Probably the food.
And the people. I don't know, Kavita. People, eh.
Go to Lex's podcast. Yes, I'm just going to arrive at his house,
and that's how you get a podcast as big as Lex Friedman.
While I'm at it, I'm going to make a tour of the podcast.
Lex Friedman, Joe Rogan. I'm just going to arrive at their studio, and that's how it works.
Yep.
You know, the requests that they get per day, yeah, it's crazy.
That's why when I sent that message, I don't think it's going to land even in the right pile.
Maybe I'll go on the Alex Jones podcast while I'm at it.
So did you know that not a single one of the World Championship matches actually happened?
In fact, Wilhelm Steinitz is actually an alien, and he is the UFO that infiltrated the Earth and decided to play chess.
Okay, let's go here.
Tardikauer presiding? Yeah, Tardikauer is definitely suspicious.
My headphones are dying.
Yeah, honestly, Lex Friedman is super popular these days.
I was discussing this with someone.
Honestly, I find it very, very difficult to get through.
I would go on his podcast, but I find it difficult to actually get through an entire episode.
I don't know what it is, but I just find it hard to...
Maybe it's his voice, but I don't know what it is exactly, but it's...
I don't know. It's hard.
The guests are really interesting, but it's difficult for me to actually listen to an entire podcast.
Don't you get annoyed by Russians practically begging you?
Nobody's begging me to speak Russian.
And the people who do that are mostly not Russians.
And in fact, when I stream in Russian, it's mostly non-Russians who are trolling and getting offended that I'm not doing a stream in English.
I don't know. It's the voice.
I also struggled to get through most podcasts. That's true.
Yes, I have listened to the Sam Harris podcast, but also the same issue.
I don't think I've gotten through a complete episode.
But there are some ones I liked.
Yeah, there are.
Boring.
You're just salty he didn't invite you.
All right, let's go here.
Shit.
I am busted here. Let's see if I can swindle him.
Problem is this move is pretty, but it doesn't create a threat.
We don't speak Russian here.
We don't speak Russian.
I don't know Russian.
Okay, I've got to flag his ass.
Who da bullet boss? Who da bullet boss?
Now you're my territory boy.
Are you going to win that pawn?
How about that?
Some of that? That's right.
There's more where that came from. That's right. Exactly.
I'm pretty sure I use it sparingly, don't I?
I mean, I think it's a pretty, very pretty accent.
Can you use the southern accent accent commentator tournament?
I don't know about that.
For the entirety of the commentary. Yes.
That's the best way for me to like drive every single person crazy.
Yeah, I should do it in like a complete deadpan like as if as if nothing's the matter and then deny. Yeah, deny that I ever sounded differently like what's the big like why are you.
What's the matter like what was sounded like this.
Gas lighting. Yeah.
Okay, I'm kind of getting crushed here out of the opening.
Okay, I'm just going to get out of there.
Well look at this position and I'm got like no pieces developed that's the problem.
Yeah, like the Hans accent, that was crazy.
Should take say six.
Yeah, he finds this move.
Yeah, it's over.
That was a terrible game unfortunately terrible game.
I just didn't get my pieces out unfortunately.
Okay, can I find a swindle here.
Let's start with a check.
I'm trying to swindle him.
Yeah, I'm just trying to find his accents in general I just think.
He spots tactics so fast it's actually pretty wild.
Dude I might have just spotted the craziest perpetual check of all time. I think I might have just spotted an insane perpetual if I calculated this correctly.
This pattern King e1 Queen g1 Queen f1 Queen e3. I'm two pieces down but it's perpetual.
Oh, that's, that's cool.
Yeah, that's nice Queen f1 Queen e3.
That's actually pretty hard to believe.
All right, last one with him.
And we'll just read about morphing.
That is very satisfying, but okay.
Classic triple stack right triangle wrote wrote to juice juicer Thank you thank you grusky meerkat something so much thanks so much. Thank you so much Persian for the something so much.
I might playing.
Definitely Fisher.
Unfortunately Fisher turn nasty when he, you know, when his issues came up to the surface.
Morphe not so much.
Are you trolling I slaughter poppies or do you have evidence of that.
Thanks.
God this guy so fast. Use it for movies like yeah no I calculated this and I want to let you know that I calculated that.
What's up Hannah.
Yeah, Fisher totally was crazy. It's like saying saying Fisher didn't have like massive mental issues is just totally, I mean, off the wall.
And they were manifested for like decades even before he started saying like super nasty stuff in the 2000s.
I mean even in the 70s, it was, you know, clear that he was, I mean even with his demands of tournaments and fear that his food was poison and stuff like it was obvious that he was moving in kind of the wrong direction.
That's a nice take. So it's right.
I mean obviously he could act normally, and in the 70s.
He, like if you watch talk shows with him and stuff like he's, he sounds totally normal but that, you know, would be simplistic to say that like oh, you know these these issues like manifested themselves gradually.
Okay, there's absolutely no need to give up this phone stupid doesn't take it.
Okay, bye bye.
Genius is close to madness.
Okay.
I don't think he's them I mean, this is our usual score.
He takes f7 in the game in the opening. Let's see.
Where.
Oh, you're absolutely right. I did a bishop of seven.
Damn girl.
This idea.
Now it's not, it's not that clear because he might trap my night but it appears that he doesn't trap it easily because I'm defending be seven.
It's a very famous game, Judith Polgar against Boris Spassky they played a match, a classical match and Polgar. So they went down one of the main lines of the real Lopez.
So, they were playing the sides of variation and Spassky in this position.
Let me remember how this went.
How did he go under this oh yeah.
There there there.
How did they get this trick is Polgar accidentally
didn't oh night be a.
Yeah, night be a this is the briar variation, which is very popular and in this position, the move is Bishop be seven.
But Spassky played rookie a on accident and Polgar instantly played night f1, which is the main line, which is basically like Bishop c2 or whatever missing Bishop takes have seven check one zero.
Because just it's so rare for like a top player to miss something like this and both players just assume that they were following theory.
So honestly, it was a crazy moment there have been some moments like this where like an opening mix up was ignored by both players.
It is a cool time I really like and of course there's the very famous Fisher Ryszewski game from the US championship years ago. Speaking of Fisher, where Ryszewski.
Let's see if I can remember it from memory.
Remember it from memory that makes a lot of sense.
Fisher Ryszewski. No, I think Ryszewski played g6.
Let me look it up. I don't remember exactly the move order.
Remember from memory. No, let me look up the game.
It was like night f6 here I think.
So like Ryszewski basically tried a weird Sicilian and he just got burned instantly.
It's a pretty well-known game.
Yeah, there it is. So it was an accelerated dragon.
It was an accelerated dragon main line and Ryszewski played castles, bishop b3, knight a5.
So the main move here even today is a5.
But Ryszewski tries this new move, knight a5. And Fisher just eats him alive. 1958, New York.
e5, knight e8. I wonder how many of you know this game.
And here out of a completely clear blue sky, bishop takes f7 check is winning.
Beautiful tactic. Because the queen is undefended and the queens are x-raying each other.
So this traps the queen and you can't take, well Ryszewski did end up taking but he lost the queen.
And if king takes f7, you still go knight e6.
Again, de queen takes d8 is winning.
And if king takes e6, there's like obvious checkmate.
There's maiden five with g4, rook g1.
And now anticlimactic but okay, just like queen e4 and queen g4.
Or queen back to g2 with too many mate threats.
Yeah, that is, it is honestly crazy how these tactics can occur out of absolutely nowhere.
Bishop takes f7 tactics in general are extremely widespread in a lot of different openings.
So it's always worth paying attention to those types of tactics.
I had a game I remember that was super satisfying.
And it was satisfying because my opponent in this game was an old Russian dude
who had beaten me at our chess club in San Francisco like a thousand times.
And I finally beat him.
Yeah, so basically in this position, this is obviously a Ruy Lopez.
At this point, I already cooked up a tactic.
So I played bishop b3 and I was like, please move your d-pawn.
Please move your d-pawn and he instantly plays d4.
And obviously, bishop takes f7 check again.
And this is very easy. I mean, he went king h8 and gave up the exchange.
This is already game over because if he goes king g7, then there's knight e6 check and wins the queen.
King g8, queen b3, and knight f7 wins the queen as well.
So anyways, worthwhile tactic.
All right, I'll be right back.
Then I'll finish off the Morphy thread and then we'll maybe play a couple more games and call it a night.
Max Lang on Morphy.
Here's what he said.
This is actually what I started earlier.
So this is in 1860.
Morphy plays five games simultaneously against some of the most expert players, including the well-known French player M. de Riviere.
The tables were arranged in a row, each table being occupied on the one side by a player.
And then the other passage was left free, along which the single antagonist, that is Morphy, might pass backwards and forwards.
With regards to this exciting feat, a contemporary remarks.
Mr. Morphy seems to play perfectly at ease, generally making his moves with great rapidity,
although sometimes stopping and seeming to give the move in hand a good deal of careful consideration.
We endeavored to ascertain whether, like other great players, he had any favorite move or leading idea in his play.
And there did seem to be a little uniformity in the cases in which he obtained the first move.
So he played both white and black.
Okay, this is a meaningless phrase, so clearly this person is not a chess player.
But as this happened only in two cases out of the five, he was in the other three necessarily influenced by the opening of his opponent.
Speaking generally, his style of play seems to be rapid and impetuous,
and is so perfect that he can master at one glance all the exigencies of the board.
More than once in the course of play, his opponents had to call for time, which he conceded with the most good-humored courtesy.
So that basically means in a simul, when you arrive at the board, your opponent is supposed to make his move.
But people have a certain amount of passes, like you can take another pass through to think.
So that's what that means.
Which he conceded with the most good-humored courtesy, chatting in the interim carelessly with whoever chanced to stand near him.
That's his ultimate flex.
The great secret of his success as a chess player would appear to lie in the wonderful power and tenacity of his memory.
He plays the most abstruse and reflective of known games.
The only advantage he has is the prestige of his wonderful name, blah, blah, blah,
which certainly had considerable effect in producing caution on the part of his opponents, so people were obviously scared of him.
The games took place in the elegant and capacious smoking room of the St. James restaurant,
and all the players to whom Mr. Morphy was opposed worshipped the genius, worshipped his genius.
We observed, however, that he did not smoke, an important fact for the modern advocates of the counterblast.
Mr. Morphy, although an American, would appear to deny himself his cigar in order to secure the necessary amount of cerebral lucidity.
So Morphy was playing Deriviere Bowden of Bowden's Mate, Barnes, who was one of the top English players, Lowenthal, and Bird.
So he was playing five of the top European players simultaneously.
The play commenced at 6 o'clock p.m. and was kept up with great spirit until the late hour of the night.
The following was the result.
The game of the first board was won by Morphy.
Second game was a draw.
Third won by Barnes.
Fourth by Morphy. Fifth, a draw.
So he didn't do amazing.
We give below four out of the five games played on this occasion.
The game with Mr. Barnes not having come to our knowledge, of course, somehow.
Conveniently, the one Morphy lost was not available.
Yeah, long games.
A few days after this, Simon Morphy left England on board the Persia.
Interesting.
Very interesting.
Wow, look at this.
And he didn't just play an over-the-board simul.
So he played a match with a French player named Mangretian, who he crushed.
Then he returns to England.
And he arrives at the London Chess Club.
We hail the arrival of this extraordinary genius for a keen and just appreciation of his abilities.
Blah, blah, blah. Will Dallas make an epoch still more glorious and remarkable?
Mr. Morphy arrived in town last Saturday.
And on the next Tuesday, visited St. James' Hall, where a host of noted chess players were assembled to welcome him amongst their circles.
On the following day, he went to the London Chess Club, where for the third time since he arrived in Europe,
he exhibited the wonderful feat of playing eight blindfold games simultaneously against the strongest players of the club,
out of which he won two.
The remaining six were given up as drawn on account of the lateness of the hour.
OK, all right. Or maybe he forgot the positions, which is, I think, more likely.
This astonishing performance commenced at 5 p.m. and lasted till after midnight.
Seven hours of blindfold. OK, that is crazy.
On the following day, a dinner was given in honor of our hero by the London Chess Club.
All the top players were present.
Wow. That's pretty crazy.
So before he came to England, he was in France.
Wow. Called out.
So he crushes this guy, Mungradian, and it wasn't even close.
The brilliant career of our distinguished countryman was for Paul Morphy,
whose services to the game of chess can hardly be overestimated.
And then he was in Germany before he went to France.
Wow.
The challenge of the veteran English champion Staunton by the young American has given occasion to a well-known and greatly extended controversy,
in the course of which both parties often went too far.
The blamable point of the Englishman's conduct is one of precision in his declarations
and in keeping up with his well-known pretensions.
Staunton, as a man of honor, cannot be wholly excused as he has not behaved generously,
but a bad intention can by no means be proved against him, nor anything which may be considered.
So this was the drama of the day.
This was the Hans Niemann affair of the 1850s, is why Staunton was not playing Morphy.
It may, however, be taken as a real fact that public opinion has judged his strength to be decidedly inferior to that of the American.
So everybody knew what was going on.
Interesting.
Mr. Morphy hopes before returning to this country to have the pleasure of contending against Mr. Max Ling,
and he's giving odds of pawn and move to everybody.
So he would give them the odds.
He would essentially start the game without a pawn, and they would have the first move.
So let's see.
Wow.
His schedule in Europe was crazy.
Two simultaneous blindfold games.
He was in Mexico playing a match with Lowenthal, who was one of the top European players, and crushing him.
Yeah, pretty interesting.
Yeah, so here Max Ling talks about Morphy's style.
Okay, so Morphy was a genius.
A few words under that of memory.
Mr. Morphy seems to forget nothing, from the game which he himself played yesterday to that which he read in the Chess Chronicle a year ago.
Playing blindfold without the sight of a board.
Yeah.
Inventive power, power of analysis.
Style of play is singularly fearless.
More so, we must confess, than any of which we have yet seen opposed to it.
He is ready to accept any of the most critical gambits.
Yeah.
Interesting.
I'll read more about this.
I'll read more of this book later and maybe share some interesting passages.
Foolish invention of the daily paper.
So this was published in the newspapers.
Morphy and Staunton's back and forth.
Yeah.
Very interesting.
Morphy was also of course playing Adolph Anderson, who was a top German player of the day, and basically crushed him in every match.
Anyways, back to the chess.
Let's play until maybe three, couple more games.
Couple more games.
What book is this, this is by Max Ling from 1860 so this was written during Morphy's life.
It's a Morphy's biography and annotated games.
Match with Anderson.
Wow, extensive annotations.
But I was really interested to see how people perceived him during his life like did people realize that he was the greatest player of all time, or greatest player of his day and the answer is yes.
Like it was, even though there was no there were no ratings. Everybody knew that he was basically, you know, in a league of his own.
So it's not the case, a lot of people seem to claim that you know these players are only appreciated after they died but that was not true in Morphy's case.
He was idolized by everybody across the world.
So, when Morphy came to Europe, Adolf Anderson was considered the top player, because Stanton was retired.
Because Stanton was retired.
Wow, so Anderson was so excited to face Morphy that he came to Paris to meet him and prepared for every risk but his championship and well earned laurel crown into the scales played for no money.
Anderson. First, first to seven would be the victor, a whole of the match consisting of 11 games, some of which are very obstinate and attested lasted a week.
Morphy seven Anderson two and two drawn games not even close.
Not even close.
The American tried a new attack in the real Lopez opening, which variation though introduced into practice by German players is comparatively little known.
Every game was won by the American champion through an evident mistake as opponent.
Because the King's Gambit was obviously the, you know, main opening of the day.
An American master exhibitors perfect knowledge of the Sicilian opening thing it's the so called French opening.
Yeah.
So he definitely analyzed openings and stuff a lot more carefully than his contemporaries.
Tons of annotated games.
So then he played play to the French players.
Bill Stein is Doug more because he knew what would happen.
Bill Stein is Bill.
Bill.
Here we go with this again.
More if you played another eight board blindfold simul the sitting lasted 10 hours.
These two players are the first to surrender a nine o'clock was a drawn game and rejoice at its acceptance.
When the clock struck 10 the last opponent surrender thereupon followed a thunder of applause, which continued so long that Murphy was in literal sense stunned by it.
He won the game blindfold simul and he wins seven of them. Not too bad. And Littleton the president of the English Federation characterized his feat of playing eight opponents that one's blindfold is the most wonderful thing he had ever seen.
Mr. Murphy expresses deep sense of gratitude.
Mr. Murphy not only played eight games in his head but he also played them in a masterly style which is evident by his victories over strong players. Besides his combinations by their soundness and depth produced general astonishment and the performance made upon those present an impression of the miraculous and incredible.
An eight boards eight board blindfold simul is still very impressive. Magnus did 10 boards, but I would not be able to do more than three is already like pushing it.
So eight boards blindfold is crazy with with like good players.
He sat at one end of the room and at eight tables at the other were his opponents.
The eyes of our hero were directed toward the window opposite him his arm carelessly thrown over a chair.
And thus he gave move after move following the numbers of the boards as it's still done now.
We cannot attach any weight to the assertion made by some correspondence on acquainted with chess the blindfold player corrected some false moves which were reported to him in consequence of an accidental disagreement disarrangement of the pieces.
As this would prove a great weakness on the part of his adversaries.
So, yeah, no, obviously, the moves would have to be communicated correctly to him.
Yeah, the blindfold time was the most impressive thing to most people not his actual matches.
So here we go this again young Bobby Fisher some more if he arrives in England, and
The president says he hopes that Morphe would come off victorious in all his encounters but one,
and that he hoped the veteran English player Staunton would be the counterer,
but the match with Staunton would not take place.
For the English champion, it appears, had not fully made up his mind to enter the contest.
Nice.
Yeah. A shame.
The umpires, Mr. Staunton.
So Morphe, before that, plays Lowenthal in England, Lowenthal being top five in the world.
Staunton accepted the match but asked for an indefinite delay.
In the meantime, Morphe played another match with Lowenthal and Morphe crushes him.
The winner of the first nine games was to bear the stake of 100 pounds.
Not bad.
Thus, the analytical result of the match points out the European player's remarkable theoretical knowledge,
the American the superior practical player.
Yeah.
So Morphe crushes Lowenthal.
Long voyage. Mr. Morphe has played some chess games in London,
but probably has not recovered from his fatigues of his voyage from America.
Morphe's long voyage by sea, a thing to which he was totally unaccustomed,
caused him to meet the strong players of the clubs and divans of London at a disadvantage, gel lag.
But as soon as the effects of travel passed away, he was himself again.
Interesting.
Overcome the long fatigues of a sea voyage and the uncomfortable feelings of first impressions in a strange country.
Yeah.
I didn't even know this book existed.
So here they discuss what openings he plays.
He would have placed Peculiarity Morphe, who in close games systematically places the bishop behind the center pawn.
Strikes us, however, with an extraordinary opening.
Close though it may be, Morphe may have deviated from his sound and usual practice.
Founded on deep study of modern chess works, among which perhaps are several books that Morphe read.
Mr. Barnes, one of the strongest members of the St. George Chess Club,
kept his ground against Morphe in the beginning, each having won four games.
After he recovered the consciousness of his superiority, his confidence returned with it.
I can beat that man and I shall beat him, he exclaimed.
And finally, he won 19 games to his opponent's seven.
Damn girl.
In the St. George's Club, where his reception was very cordial,
he is reported to have expressed his desire to play one of the strong English players,
a match for stakes from 100 pounds to 1,000 pounds, according to his opponent's wishes.
The next day, he visited the newly opened Philidor chess room
and rejoiced those present by a splendid specimen of blindfold play.
No, this is a mistake.
Oh, sorry, this is a report from the newspaper, but Max Lang says this is a mistake.
Morphe did not play blindfold in the Philidor chess room, but took part in a game of four,
playing with Moklau against Brian and Falkbeer, who developed the Falkbeer Gambit.
It's funny that all these, like, people after whom the openings were named were just, like, people.
The game resulted in basically hand and brain.
Or alternate moves, I think.
On the 8th of June in the morning, Morphe made his appearance in New York
in order to embark next day in the steamer Arabia for the Old World.
Let's see how long it took him.
On Wednesday the 23rd.
Okay, not that long, 15 days.
It wasn't that crazy.
A voyage across the ocean in the interest of chess was something so new and romantic
that external impediments insensibly disappeared before so enchanting a prospect.
Interesting.
Oh, here we go with this again.
Morphe goes after Staunton.
Okay, this is funny.
October 6th.
Sir, on my arrival in England three months ago, I renewed the challenge to you personally,
which the New Orleans Chess Club had given you previously.
You immediately accepted, but demanded a month's delay in order to prepare yourself for the match.
Okay.
Subsequently, you proposed that the time should be postponed until after the Birmingham tournament,
to which I agreed.
On the approach of the period you had fixed, I addressed you a communication request
that the necessary preliminaries might be settled, but you left London without replying to it.
I went to Birmingham for the express purpose of asking you to put a stop to this delay
by fixing a date for the opening of our match.
But before the opportunity presented itself, you came to me, and in the presence of Littleton,
the president of the English Chess Club, you stated that your time was much occupied
in editing a new edition of Shakespeare, and that you were under heavy bonds to your publisher.
But you reiterated your intention to play me, and said that if I would consent to further postpone
until the first week of November, you would within a few days communicate with me the exact date.
I have not heard from you further, either privately by letter or through the columns of the London Chess News.
Permit me to repeat what I have invariably declared in every chess community,
that I am not a professional chess player, that I never wish to make my skill I possess
the means of peculiar advancement, my earnest wish is never to play for any stake but honour.
My friends in New Orleans, however, have proposed a sum, sponsor, that sum has been ready for you
Considerable time passed, since my arrival in Paris, I have been assured by numerous gentlemen
that the value of these stakes can be immediately increased to any amount, so this match would have been sponsored,
but for myself personally, reputation is the only incentive I recognize.
I have the honour to remain your humble servant, Paul Morphy.
Staunton replies,
Oh God. Sir, in reply to your letter, I have to observe that you must be perfectly conscious
that the difficulty in the way of my engaging in a chess match is one over which I have no control.
You were distinctly apprised in answer to the extraordinary proposal of your friends
that I should leave my home, my family, and my job, and proceed to New Orleans
for the purpose of playing chess with you.
That a long and arduous contest, even in London, would be an undertaking too formidable for me to embark
without ample opportunity for the recovery of my old strength in play,
together with such arrangements as would prevent the sacrifice of my professional engagements.
Upon your unexpected arrival in Europe, the same thing was repeated to you,
and my acceptance of your challenge was entirely conditional on my being able to gain time for practice.
The experience, however, of some weeks, during which I have laboured unceasingly
to the serious injury of my health, shows that it is not only impossible for me to save time for the purpose,
but by no means short of giving up a great work on which I am engaged, to be continued.
A match at chess or cricket may be a very good thing on its own,
but nobody but a madman would forfeit his engagements and imperil his professional reputations.
Okay, yeah, this gets interesting.
I did not realize that they, um, went after each other like that.